حول التلفاز والموقد يتجمع بعض سكان بخموت
ليسوا بحاجه لمتابعه نشرات الاخبار كي
يدركوا سوء الاوضاع في مدينتهم
منزلي اصبح من دون نوافذ ومن دون ابواب
كما انقطعت التدفئه تحطمت ابواب المبنى
سكني ما يمكن اي شخص من الدخول واخذ ما
يريد
اللقطات الجويه تظهر حجم الدمار اللاحق
بالمدينه كما المعارك المحتدمه وهو ما اتى
الرئيس الاوكراني على ذكره في مداخلته
المسائيه
صعوبه حول مدينه بخموت العدو يدمر بشكل
متواصل كلما يمكن استخدامه لحمايه مواقعنا
جنودنا الذين يدافعون عن المنطقه المحيطه
بمخموت هم ابطال حقيقيون
بالرغم من اعلان رئيس جمهوريه دونيسكي
الشعبيه المواليه لموسكو ان كل الطرق
المؤديه الى بخموت باتت تحت سيطره القوات
المواليه لروسيا يتمسك الجنود الاوكرانيون
بالدفاع عن مواقعهم
عندما يهاجمنا الروس فانهم يتكبدون خسائر
اكثر منا بالنسبه لنا من الاسهل والافضل
صدهم لانهم يفقدون المزيد من المعدات
والارواح لدينا غرفه عمليات مركزيه يديرها
اشخاص اذكياء وعليهم التفكير بشان الشن
هجوم مضاد
وتعد المعركه الدائره للسيطره على محمود
الاطول التي خاضتها روسيا حتى الان منذ
غزوها اوكرانيا وبينما يرى مراقبون ان هذا
الامر لن يعدوا كونه رمزيا نظرا للاهميه
الاستراتيجيه المحدوده للمدينه ينظر اخرون
الى مخبوط كمركز مهم لامداد القوات
الاوكرانيه في منطقه الدومباس